next something like all the Visions have
found to not be following best practices
what's often dangerous is to write
action titles with really hard absolute
statements always never in every case
this is like this or like that so these
are very hard statements often are traps
just my personal learning but often
especially if we presented maybe there's
like one board member sitting in the
audience who will tell you no but this
is not correct this is wrong because you
know it's just enough to have one
example that contradicts this and then
pretty much you're there I need to admit
that yes your message was wrong